With the foreperson that
the jury has selected.
Please stand and state your number
over 19.
Thank you.
Has the jury reached a verdict?
Will you please hand it to the bailiff?
And the bailiff will bring it to me.
Thank you.
You may be seated.
Will now have the clerk read the verdict.
You can just read the question.
Answer?
Yes.
Okay.
Was Gwyneth Paltrow at fault?
No.
Was Gwyneth
Paltrow's fault
a cause of Terry Sanderson's harm?
Oh,
there's just no response there.
Was Terry Sanderson at fault?
Yes, it was Terry Sanderson's fault.
Cause Gwyneth Paltrow
did.
Did Terry Sanderson's fault cause
Gwyneth Paltrow's harm?
Yes.
Comparative fault.
What percent of the fault
do you assign to Terry Sanderson?
100%
damages.
What amount?
Fairly commensurate
can compensate Gwyneth Paltrow
for economic damages?
$1 nice.
Signed March 30th, 2023.
Thank you.
So to
to juror number 19,
the foreperson, is this your verdict?
Yes, sir. Thank you.
And the attorneys have asked
that I pull the jury and I
so I need to ask each one of you
if this is your verdict.
This is not an unusual thing to happen.
It happens quite often.
So number 16, is this your verdict?
Yes, your honor.
Thank you.
Number 11, is this your verdict?
Yes, Your Honor.
Number eight, is this your verdict?
Yes, your honor.
Number two, is this your verdict?
Yes, sure.
I've already covered number 19.
Number 28. Is this your verdict?
Yes, Your Honor.
Number 29. Is this your verdict?
And number 32, is this your verdict?
Yes, Your Honor. Thank you.
So to the attorneys, is there
anything further
before I discharged the jury
for the plaintiff? No.
Thank you, Your Honor. Okay.
Thank you.
Let me just read you
the last jury instruction.
Ladies and gentlemen of the jury,
this trial is finished.
Thank you for your service.
The American system of justice relies
on your time and your sound judgment.
And you have been generous with both.
You serve justice
by your fair and impartial decision.
I hope you found the experience
rewarding.
You may now
talk about this case
with anyone you like.
You may be contacted by the press
or by the lawyers.
You do not have to talk to them
or with anyone else, but you may.
The choice is entirely yours.
I turn now to the lawyers
and to the press
and ask them to honor your wishes.
If you say that
you do not want to talk about the case,
if you do decide to talk about the case,
please respect the privacy
of your fellow jurors.
The Court
The confidences
that they may have shared with you
while deliberating
are not yours to share with others.
Again, thank you for your service.
You may now retire.
And if everybody else would
please remain here.
We've got some things to do.
All right. The jury.